uh asked on fox news why
uh gun deaths in the united states are
so much higher than in comparable
countries congressman steve scalise
blamed the defund the police movement
and unfortunately the fox news host in
question john roberts didn't even
attempt to push back so there's a lot
behind this and we've been talking about
the the senseless i mean just bizarre
justifications and explanations that
republicans and the pro-gun right have
given for why we have mass shootings in
the u.s and you don't see them in other
countries they've talked about covet
even though every country had coveted
video games doors they haven't gotten to
windows yet but maybe they will uh but
this is a good question why why is this
a problem here and almost nowhere else
at least in terms of western countries
here is steve scalise attempt at
explaining it
let me move ahead to what's going on in
this country because in terms of the
developed world the united states far
and away leads every other nation in the
developed world true in terms of gun
violence hey and good for fox they put
up a chart showing how insanely higher
the rate of uh of gun violence deaths is
in the u.s than in any other country
good for fox for at least doing that
look at this graph the us way out in
front with four deaths per 100 000
people the next closest nation is cyprus
way behind at just below 0.7 deaths per
100 people
what do you think is responsible for
that discrepancy
well in a lot of those countries first
of all i mean you look at america in the
last couple of years you've seen this
crazy defund the police movement but
you've also seen a movement that's been
going on for a few years
in big cities where the da's aren't even
prosecuting criminals until it is a
shooting or a violent crime and
what what is this guy talking about
first of all
defund the police is a slogan almost no
departments have substantially defunded
anything some have reallocated funds
some have increased funding to police
but i'll think about another thing
the police departments in many of those
other countries on the list
are already more like the police
departments that the reform the police
movement wants anyway so think about
that they're saying the defund the
police movement is responsible it's a
slogan that's accomplished almost
nothing but if it did all it would do is
make police departments look more like
the police department in italy uh in
france in other places where not
necessarily all officers have firearms
or you don't necessarily have an armed
response to every 9-1-1 call but the
idea that there are mass shootings p the
the mass shooters who they say are
mentally ill
are deciding whether to go and do
shootings
based on what da's are doing like it
it's completely incoherent letting
criminals back out on the streets and
inevitably what you see is higher rates
of crime
it's it's completely absurd these mass
shootings were not criminals that had
been left out but left back out on the
street let back out what you're also
seeing is more and more american
citizens law-abiding citizens are buying
guns to defend themselves but the
question was why do we have so many
shootings and he's saying well all these
citizens are buying guns to defend
themselves he's not trying to make that
point but he's almost inadvertently
making it more guns makes it more
dangerous it's happening in every
demographic group you can imagine where
you have large increases in people
buying guns because if they can't have
faith that their local police department
that's been defunded uh can arrive
quickly
this guy's disgusting as you know barely
any any defunding has taken place and
it's just it's it's a slogan and blaming
the epidemic of gun violence on a slogan
that first of all is very new
defund the police as a as a widespread
slogan
which by the way
almost no one on the left supports i
mean quite literally almost no one you
do polling most of the left wants to
reform the police they don't want to
defund it
that's what you're blaming it on and
what about all the mass shootings that
have taken place before that became a
slogan now i tweeted something similar
how do they explain it i tweeted quote
it would be interesting to figure out
why a country like italy for example has
essentially no mass shootings they have
economic problems they have diversity
you know sometimes the right life's to
say well
homogeneous countries have less violence
like countries like you know they often
point to norway or whatever
italy is a diverse country uh
what but they have almost no mass
shootings what could be the reason and
the great betsy brant who played marie
on breaking bad responded no one knows
of course tongue-in-cheek
the guns are the difference and people
jokingly responded and said well italy
has fresh pasta
uh italy doesn't have doors of course
that's a joke but in all seriousness
italy has doors and they have video
games and they had coveted mandates they
have everything other than as many guns
as we have per capita and they don't
have toxic american gun culture it's
both things
so any sensible person can see it's
pointing very strongly to the guns deal
with everything else sure but you've got
to deal with the guns as well now in
addition
um
the the the pointing fingers that the
defund the police movement yeah the the
uvalde texas pd department uh pd
police department was well funded and in
fact the police department there
had 40 percent of the city's budget so
think about that 40 percent of the
budget in valdez is police
they have everything they need to go in
and stop a shooter
and they stood outside for an hour so at
least as far as that's concerned
defund the police a non-factor
and steve scalise is doing what they all
do just running interference that's all
they want to do uh they're not going to
stop they don't want to deal with guns
in any serious way and this is what you
get by the way
four five six mass shootings over the
weekend i mean we can't even keep track
at this point they didn't all make
national news
every day could just be the mass
shooting show where i just talk about
all we we would need multiple hours a
day
to fully cover every mass shooting in
the united states
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping